Professor Shelly Kagan:
We've been working our way
through Plato's arguments for
the immortality of the soul.
And last time I spent a fair
bit of time working through
objections to,
not quite the last argument
we're going to look at,
but the penultimate argument,
in which Plato tries to argue
for the simplicity of the soul.
The set of connected ideas,
you'll recall,
were these: that Plato wants to
suggest that in order to be
destroyed you've got to have
parts;
to destroy something is to
basically take its parts apart.
If he could only convince us
that the soul was simple,
it would follow that it was
indestructible and,
hence, immortal.
He asks, what's our evidence
for some things being
indestructible?
What kinds of things are simple?
Well, these are--he then goes
on to claim--invisible things,
things that don't change.
After all, changing is a matter
of the rearrangement of the
parts.
And so, if something can
change, it can't be simple.
Maybe it could be destroyed.
But if we could become
convinced that the soul was not
composite, if it was something
that couldn't change,
then it would simple.
Perhaps then it would
indestructible.
And then he goes on to suggest
that the invisibility of the
soul is evidence for it's being
changeless, and hence simple,
and hence indestructible.
So that's the argument we
worked through last time.
And I spent a fair bit of time
suggesting that if you pin down
precisely what Plato means by
invisible, the argument doesn't
actually go through.
Before leaving that argument,
there are a couple of extra
remarks I want to make about it.
First, we probably shouldn't
have been so quick to want to
buy into the suggestion that the
soul is changeless.
After all, if you think about
it, it seems that at least on
the face of it the soul does
indeed change.
On one day you believe,
for example,
that it's hot;
on another day you believe that
it's cold.
On one day you believe that so
and so is a nice person;
on the next day you believe
that so and so is a mean person.
You desire to learn the piano,
the next day you give up on
that desire.
Your beliefs,
your goals, your intentions,
your desires--these things are
all constantly changing.
And so, at least on the face of
it, it looks as though we might
well want to say the soul--if we
do believe there are souls--the
soul is changing as well,
in terms of what thoughts and
beliefs it's housing.
So we should have been
skeptical in the first place of
any argument that said,
based on the invisibility of
the soul, we can conclude that
it's changeless.
It doesn't seem to be in fact
changeless.
Furthermore,
we should be,
or at least we might well be,
skeptical of the claim that the
soul is simple.
Indeed, Plato himself,
in other dialogues,
argues against the simplicity
of the soul.
Now, that doesn't mean he's
right in the other dialogues,
but at least suggests that we
shouldn't be so ready to assume
that sort of position is
correct.
In The Republic,
famously, Plato goes on to
argue that the soul has at least
three different parts.
There's a rational part that's
in charge of reasoning;
there's a spirited part that's
sort of like the will;
there's a part that has to do
with appetite,
desires for food,
drink, sex, what have you.
Plato elsewhere argues the soul
is not simple at all.
So perhaps it shouldn't shock
us that the argument he's
sketching here for the
simplicity of the soul based on
the changeless,
invisible nature of the
soul--perhaps it shouldn't shock
us that that argument doesn't
succeed after all.
Finally, although I gave Plato,
previously, the assumption that
if only we could establish the
simplicity of the soul,
it would follow that soul was
indestructible--after all,
you couldn't break a soul by
tearing its pieces apart if it
didn't have pieces,
if it didn't have
parts--nonetheless,
I just want to register the
thought that it's not actually
obvious that simples can't be
destroyed.
Well, they clearly can't be
destroyed by the particular
method of destruction that
involves taking them apart.
If they don't have parts,
you can't take them apart.
But for all that,
it still seems conceptually
possible for a simple to be
destroyed in the following
sense: it goes out of existence.
After all, where did the
simples come from in the first
place?
Well, at least from a logical
point of view,
it seems as though there's no
difficulty in imagining that at
one point a given simple didn't
exist and then at the next point
it popped into existence.
Well, how did that happen?
Maybe God said--God says at the
beginning of Genesis,
"Let there be light."
So maybe He says,
"Let there be simples."
At a given moment they weren't
there;
the next moment they were.
Well, after a while maybe God
says, "Let the simples no longer
exist."
Given moment there they were;
the next moment,
they no longer exist.
Seems as though that idea makes
sense, and so even if we agreed
that the soul was simple,
even if we granted everything
in Plato's argument up to this
point and said,
"the soul really is simple," it
still wouldn't follow that it's
immortal.
We'd still have to worry about
the possibility that the simple
soul might simply pop out of
existence at a given point,
perhaps the very point when the
body gets destroyed.
So I'm inclined to think that
this most recent argument of
Plato's--the argument from
simplicity--no,
that's not successful either.
Before leaving that argument,
there's one other piece
of business I want to discuss.
This is a footnote that I put
aside, a point that I put aside
previously.
You'll recall that we were
worried about--The objection got
raised the right way to think
about the soul is like the
harmony of a harp.
And this was originally offered
as a counterexample to the
thought that invisible things
couldn't be destroyed.
But harmony could be destroyed.
It was invisible,
so invisible things could be
destroyed.
But I noticed,
I mentioned that,
look, whether or not this is a
problem for the argument,
it's an interesting suggestion
in its own right.
Because the suggestion that the
mind is to the body,
the soul is to the body,
like harmony is to an
instrument with strings,
seems to me to be an early
attempt to describe something
like the physicalist conception
of the mind.
Just as harmony is something
that gets produced by a
well-tuned instrument,
the soul or the mind is
something that gets produced by
a well-tuned body.
Now Plato's got some objections
to the suggestion that we should
think of the mind as the harmony
of the body.
And so I want to take just a
moment and talk about those
objections because,
of course, if they were
compelling objections that might
well give us reason to doubt the
physicalist view.
Whether or not Plato's
arguments for the immortality of
the soul work,
he might still have some good
arguments against the
physicalist conception.
But in thinking about these
objections, it's important to
bear in mind that it's only
meant--the harmony analogy is
only meant--as just that,
as an analogy.
Right?
The claim isn't,
or at least it shouldn't be,
understood as saying literally,
"the mind is harmony."
It's rather,
the mind is like
harmony;
it's the sort of thing to the
body like harmony is to a harp,
something that can be produced
by a well-functioning,
well-tuned physical object.
A well-tuned instrument can
produce melody and harmony.
A well-tuned,
properly functioning body can
produce mental activity.
That's the suggestion.
And so even if it turns out
that there are some ways in
which the mind isn't exactly
like harmony,
it doesn't show us that the
physicalist view is wrong.
Well, so let's quickly look at
what Plato's arguments were.
First--this is,
I think, an interesting
argument--Plato says,
harmony clearly cannot exist
before the existence of the harp
itself.
Right?
The melodiousness of the harp
can't exist prior to the
physical construction of the
harp.
And if mind were the sort of
thing that was produced by the
proper functioning of the
physical body,
then pretty obviously the mind
could not exist prior to the
creation of the physical body.
However, Plato has already
argued earlier in the dialogue
that the soul does exist prior
to the existence of the body.
That's the argument from
recollection.
If the soul exists prior to the
body, it can't be like harmony;
physicalism has clearly got to
be false.
But I said that I didn't find
the argument--I tried to explain
why I didn't find the argument
from recollection persuasive.
I certainly do want to agree
that if we became convinced that
the soul did exist prior to the
existence of the body,
we would certainly want to
agree that the soul is not like
harmony.
But I don't think the argument
from recollection succeeds.
Plato's second objection is to
point out that harmony can vary.
We talk about the melodiousness
of the harp.
Well, it could be harmonious in
a variety of different ways and,
indeed, to different degrees.
Something--an instrument--could
be more or less harmonious.
What it's playing can be in
greater or lesser harmony.
But it doesn't seem as though
souls come in degrees.
You've got a soul or you don't
have a soul.
That's the argument,
that's the objection.
You've got a mind or you don't
have a mind.
But perhaps we should--That's
the objection,
and of course if that was right
then again we might have to
conclude,
well, whatever the mind is,
it's not quite like harmony is
to the body.
But I'm not so sure we should
agree that the mind can't come
in degrees.
It can at least--The mental
aspects can come in degrees.
We can have varying degrees of
intelligence,
varying degrees of creativity,
varying degrees of
reasonableness,
varying degrees of ability to
communicate.
So just as, we might say,
just as the functioning of the
harp can come in varying
degrees--more or less
harmony--the functioning of the
body in terms of its mind can
come in varying degrees.
So that second objection
doesn't seem to me very
compelling.
Third objection,
Plato points out--Socrates
points out--that the soul can be
good or it could be evil,
wicked.
When the soul is good,
when you've got somebody who
has got their stuff together,
we might speak of them as
having a harmonious soul.
If the soul were to the body
like harmony is to the
instrument and the soul can be
harmonious,
it would seem as though we'd
have to be able to talk about
harmony being harmonious.
So just as we can talk about
the harmony of the soul,
we'd have to be able to--if the
soul is like the harmony of the
body--we'd have to be able to
talk about the harmony of the
harmony.
But we don't talk about harmony
of the harmony.
I'm not quite sure what to make
of this objection.
This might be a point where it
would be well to remind
ourselves of the fact that the
suggestion was never that the
soul just literally is harmony.
It's just similar to harmony,
says the physicalist,
in the way that harmony gets
produced by the body--by the
instrument.
In that same way,
mind or mental activity gets
produced by the body.
We don't have to say that
everything that's true of the
mind is true of harmony and
everything that's true of
harmony is true of the body--or
the mind.
Still, I think there's a bit
more we can say in response to
this objection,
and that's this:
Just as it's true that we can
talk about minds or souls being
good or wicked,
we can talk about different
kinds of harmony.
There are--Certain harmonies
are sweeter than others;
some of them are more jarring
and atonal or discordant.
Although we might not normally
talk about how harmonious the
harmony is, it seems as though
harmonies can come in different
sorts and different kinds.
And then, it turns out we
really would have an analogy to
the mind, which can come in
different sorts and different
kinds.
So I think this third objection
isn't really compelling either.
Finally, Plato raises one more
objection.
He says, "Look,
the soul is capable of
directing the body,
bossing it around,
and indeed capable of opposing
the body."
You know, your body might want
that piece of chocolate cake,
but your soul says,
"No, no.
You're on a diet.
Don't eat it."
Right?
Your soul can oppose the body.
But if the soul was just
harmony of the body,
how could it do that?
After all, the harmoniousness
of the harp can't affect what
the harp does.
All the causal interaction is
one way, as we might put it.
In the case of the harp and the
musicality and the melodiousness
and the harmony,
the physical state of the harp
causes the melodiousness to be
the way it is.
But the harmoniousness of the
harp, doesn't ever change or
alter or direct the way the
physical object the harp is.
In contrast,
not only can the body affect
the soul, the soul can affect
the body.
So that suggests it can't
really be like harmony and the
harp after all.
I think that's a pretty
interesting objection.
Since we do think,
at least in the kind of
position that we've been taking
for this class,
that the soul can affect the
body, we might ask,
how could it be that it's--that
the physicalist view is right?
If talk about the mind is just
a way of talking about what the
body can do, how can the
abilities of the body affect the
body itself?
I think the answer to this
objection is probably going to
be something like,
what's really going on when we
talk about the soul affecting
the body is that--when we say
certain functions of the body
are affecting the body--that
certain mental functions are
affecting the body--how does
this happen causally?
Well, something like the
physical parts of the body that
underwrite, that lie beneath the
proper functioning,
the proper mental functioning
of body, those are able to alter
the other parts of the body.
So look, right now I'm telling
by body, "Wiggle my fingers."
My soul is giving instructions
to my body.
How does that happen?
That's my mind giving
instructions to my body.
How does that happen on the
physicalist view?
Well, my mind giving
instructions to my body,
"wiggle my fingers," is just
one part of my body,
my brain, giving instructions
to another part of my body,
the muscles in my fingers.
So, although we talk about the
mind altering the body,
strictly what's going on there,
says the physicalist,
is just one part of the body
affecting another part of the
body.
Can we have something like that
with a harp?
Well, maybe not.
Right?
Maybe the harp's too simple a
machine to have one part of it
affect another part of it in
that way.
Even if that were true,
that wouldn't give us reason to
reject the physicalist
conception.
It would just give us reason to
think the harp's not very
much like the mind and the body.
It's just the beginnings of a
picture, of a physicalist
picture.
Still, even if we think about
the harp and musicality,
I think we can see something
analogous.
Suppose I pluck a string on my
harp, producing a certain note.
As we know, the vibrations of
one string can set into play the
other strings vibrating as well.
And so, suddenly,
what's happening in one part of
the harp affects what's going on
in other parts of the harp.
The musicality of my playing a
certain chord on the harp may
create certain kinds of
overtones in the harp,
setting the harp vibrating in
various other ways.
Well, that would be
analogous--perhaps not a precise
analogy, but at least a rough
analogy to what goes on when my
mind affects my body--to--if one
part of my body affects other
parts of my body.
So, on the one hand,
I want to give Plato a fair bit
of credit for taking the
physicalist view seriously
enough to try to criticize it.
And since when he was writing
there weren't the kind of
complicated thinking machines
that we've got nowadays,
it's no criticism of Plato that
he used simple machines like
musical instruments to try to
think about what a physicalist
picture would look like.
I want to give him credit,
but I also want to suggest that
the objections that he raises to
the physicalist view just don't
succeed.
All right.
Now, there's one other argument
that I want to consider in our
dialogue.
And after the appeal to the
simplicity of the soul,
there's a very long complicated
discussion about what
constitutes an adequate
explanation,
and Socrates gives some of his
history there and talks about
what he's looking for in trying
to find adequate explanations of
things.
And these passages are very,
very difficult and happily for
our purposes we don't really
need to go there.
Before the dialogue ends
though, there's one further
argument, which I'll dub,
"the argument from essential
properties."
Now again, it's important to
bear in mind as we try to make
sense of this passage that Plato
is writing at a time when we
don't have,
we didn't have,
all the conceptual apparatus
that we have nowadays.
We stand on his shoulders;
we've inherited some of the
distinctions that he was the
first to try to put into play.
And so although,
again, he's about to--I'm about
to sketch or reconstruct an
argument and claim that that the
argument doesn't actually work,
this isn't really meant by way
of being dismissive of Plato.
I want to give him a tremendous
amount of credit.
He's trying to see his way
through a morass of issues that
are still confusing to us today,
though I think we can see
somewhat further than he was
able to see.
At any rate,
the distinction we need to
understand the final argument,
is the distinction between an
essential property and a
contingent property.
An essential property is a
property that a given object
must have;
it always has as long as it
exists at all.
A contingent property is a
property that an object may
have, may happen to have its
entire existence,
but could've existed without.
So my car is blue.
That's a contingent property of
my car.
I could take it to the paint
shop and get it painted red,
in which case it would be red.
It would no longer be blue,
but the car would still exist.
My car is blue,
but it could be red;
it could exist as a red car.
And even if I never,
over the entire course of
existence of my car,
never get it painted,
so that from the moment it came
into creation to the moment it
gets smashed it's always
blue--still,
we understand perfectly well
the idea that it could've been
red.
There's nothing incompatible
with the idea that this car
exists and is red.
So that's an example of a
contingent property.
And I might have a pencil,
and the pencil is whole.
And I never break it,
but I could've broken it.
That's a contingent property,
whether the pencil is whole or
broken.
I take a piece of metal;
it's a contingent property
whether it's straight or bent.
I bend it; now it's bent.
I might straighten it back out;
now it's straight.
Many, many properties are
contingent properties.
You're happy,
you're sad, you're awake,
you're asleep.
But some properties,
in contrast,
are essential properties.
For the particular thing that
we're thinking about,
it's not possible to have that
thing and not have the property
in question.
Plato gives the example of fire
and being hot.
Fire is hot.
That's a property that it's
got, but it's not a contingent
property;
it's an essential property.
It's not as though some fire is
hot and some fire is cold or,
"Oh yes, it just happens that
over the entire life of the fire
the fire is hot,
but we could have made it cold."
There's no such thing;
there could be no such thing as
cold fire.
As long as you've got a bit of
fire, it's hot.
Take away the heat,
you take away the fire,
you destroy the fire.
You can't have cold fire.
That's an example of an
essential property.
That is to say,
Plato sees, as indeed I take it
we all see at least roughly,
that there's some sort of
distinction there,
and he's trying to see his way
clear on these matters.
That remains a controversial
question today--until today.
Are there really essential
properties in the way we take
there to be?
If so, which properties are
essential?
Which ones are contingent?
Water is composed of
H_2O--that's its
atomic structure.
Is that an essential property
of water?
Could you have something that
was water without being composed
of H_2O--hydrogen and
oxygen in that way?
Well, some people say yes,
some people say no--but most of
us we want to say,
"Oh, there's an example of an
essential property.
To be water,
you must have that atomic
structure."
All right.
That's the thought.
Now, armed with this
distinction, Plato says,
"Here's an essential property
for the soul.
Wherever there's a soul,
it's alive."
Now, by "alive," I take it
Plato means it's thinking,
or it's capable of thought.
Wherever you've got a soul,
you've got something capable of
thought.
I suppose one could try to
resist this claim of Plato's,
but I find it reasonably
plausible.
I start thinking about minds,
and I ask myself,
"Could there be a mind that was
incapable of thought?"
Maybe not.
Maybe that's just built into
minds by definition.
Just like you couldn't have
something that was fire without
it being hot,
you couldn't have something
that was a mind without it being
capable of thought.
It's important to say the word
capable here.
Right?
It's not as though all minds
always are thinking.
I presume there are stretches
during the night when my mind is
not thinking,
not dreaming.
Still, it's capable of thought
even thought it's not thinking
at the time.
But you say, "No.
Here's a mind that's not even
capable of thought."
I want to say,
"Then, it's just not a mind."
So all right,
maybe being capable of thought
is an essential property of the
mind.
Plato thinks about the mind in
terms of souls,
so maybe being capable of
thought is an essential property
of the soul.
And I think that's what Plato
means when he suggests the mind
is essential--the soul is
essentially alive.
It's a necessary property,
as we might put it,
of the soul,
that it's alive,
that it's capable of thought.
So I want to say,
"Not an implausible claim."
Let's give it to Socrates.
But once we give it to
Socrates, Plato thinks now he's
pretty much done.
After all, think about what it
means to say that something's
got an essential property.
Fire's got the essential
property of being hot.
It means there are only two
possibilities.
Either you've got some fire and
it will be hot,
or the fire has been destroyed,
it's been put out.
Those are the only two
possibilities.
You either have--If heat is an
essential property of fire,
either you've got some fire and
it's hot, or the fire no longer
exists, it's been put out.
There's no third possibility of
a non-hot fire,
of a cold fire.
So, if you've got the claim
that life's an essential
property of the soul,
only two possibilities:
either you've got the soul and
it's alive--to wit,
it's capable of thought--or the
soul's been destroyed.
But Plato thinks we can rule
out that other possibility.
How?
Well, it's by thinking about
this particular essential
property.
There's nothing in the idea
that fire has the essential
property of being hot to make us
think it couldn't be destroyed,
but there is something,
Plato thinks,
in the idea of being
essentially alive to rule out
the possibility of its being
destroyed.
In fact, as you say the very
words you begin to feel the
force, the pull of Plato's
position.
If the soul is essentially
alive, if it's necessarily
alive, it's got to be alive.
It can't be destroyed.
That's, I think,
at least the kind of argument
that Plato means to put forward.
He does it in terms of the
phrase, "deathless."
He says, I want to actually get
this up here on the board.
One--life is an essential
property of the soul.
But if you think about what
that means, it follows that the
soul is deathless.
After all, if the soul is--If
it's essentially alive,
that means it can't be dead.
So it's deathless.
But after all,
anything that's deathless can't
die.
So the soul cannot die,
which is just to say it's
indestructible.
So, soul can't be destroyed.
Something like this seems to be
Plato's argument.
One, life's an essential
property of the soul,
but we can just summarize that
by saying the soul is deathless.
But if the soul is deathless,
it can't die.
If it can't die,
it can't be destroyed,
it's indestructible.
So the soul can't be destroyed.
Remember, once we said the soul
was alive, there were only two
possibilities.
If the soul was essentially
alive, either we have the soul,
it's alive, capable of thought,
or it's destroyed.
But if the soul can't be
destroyed, that leaves only the
possibility the soul is alive,
capable of thought.
That's just what Plato thinks;
the soul will always exist,
capable of thought.
Well, it won't shock you to
hear that I don't think this
argument actually works.
And I think where it goes wrong
is there's a certain kind of
ambiguity in the idea of being
deathless.
What does it mean to say that
something is deathless?
I think there are two possible
interpretations of that phrase.
If something is deathless,
then it can't be that--well,
what?
One possibility is,
it can't be that the soul
exists and is dead.
That's one possible
interpretation.
To say that something is
deathless means you'll never
have a soul that exists and the
same time that it exists it's
dead.
But there's a second possible
interpretation of deathless.
It can't be that the soul was
destroyed.
It's very easy to confuse these
two interpretations of
deathless, A and B.
And basically,
this is what I think is going
on with Plato.
He's running back and forth
between these two
interpretations.
If life is an essential
property of the soul,
then that means we will never
have, as it were,
a soul in our hand that exists
and is dead.
Just in the same way that
you'll never have a piece of
fire in your hand,
as it were, that exists and is
cold.
It can't happen.
Wherever you've got a soul,
it is alive.
So it's deathless in sense
number, in sense A.
Since wherever you've got a
soul it must be alive,
it couldn't be the case that
the soul exists and is dead.
So it's deathless in sense A.
But for all that,
it could still be,
logically speaking,
that the soul could be
destroyed, just like a fire can
be put out.
We could imagine something that
couldn't be destroyed.
Then of course it would be
deathless in sense B,
a much stronger sense of
deathless.
What Plato needs,
what Plato wants,
is to convince us that the soul
is deathless in sense B:
It's true of the soul that it
can't be that it was destroyed.
But all he's entitled to is
sense A: You'll never have a
soul that exists and is dead,
because being alive is an
essential property of the soul.
But the mere fact that where
there's a soul it's alive,
doesn't mean the soul couldn't
be destroyed.
Just like from the fact that
where there's fire it's hot
doesn't mean the fire can't be
destroyed.
It's, I think,
pretty easy to get confused in
thinking about these issues.
It's difficult to see your way
clearly to these two different
notions of deathless.
It's difficult to get to the
point where you can clearly use
the language of essential
properties without getting
screwed up.
Still, I think that's what
happened here.
We grant Plato the thought that
the soul has an essential
property of being alive;
from this, it follows that
where there's a soul it is
alive, and hence,
it's deathless in sense A.
But once we start thinking
about the category,
the notion of being deathless,
we're tempted to re-understand
that as being deathless in sense
B, can't be destroyed.
And that, I think,
doesn't follow.
All right.
Where does that leave us?
Plato's gone through a series
of arguments for the
immortality, the
indestructibility of the soul,
and I've argued that none of
them work.
Some of them are worth taking
seriously.
That's why we've spent the last
week or so going over them.
But none of them,
as far as I can see,
are successful.
And I hardly need remind you
that this comes on the heels of
a previous week or two in which
we talked about various other
arguments for the very existence
of an immaterial soul.
And I've argued that none of
those arguments work either.
As far as I can see then,
the arguments that might be
offered for the existence of an
immaterial soul,
let alone an immortal soul,
the arguments don't succeed.
It's not that the idea of a
soul is in any way silly;
it's not that it's not worth
thinking about.
It's that when we ask
ourselves, "Do we have any good
reason to believe in an
immaterial soul?"
and actually try to spell out
what those reasons might be,
as we look more carefully we
see the arguments are not very
compelling.
So I'm prepared to conclude
there is no soul.
There's no good reason to
believe in souls.
And I so I conclude--at least
there's no good enough reason to
believe in souls--and so I
conclude there are none.
And this is the position that
here on out I'm going to be
assuming for the rest of the
class.
I'm going to have us continue
to think about death,
but now think about death from
the physicalist perspective.
Given the assumption that the
body is all there is,
that talk about the mind is
just a way of talking about the
abilities of the body to do
certain special mental
activities.
There are no extra things
beyond the body,
no immaterial souls.
Now, it wouldn't be
unreasonable at this point to
accuse me of begging the
question.
After all, think about what
I've done.
I've put all of the burden of
proof on the fan of souls.
I've asked the dualist,
"Give me some reason to believe
your position."
And I've said the arguments on
behalf of dualism aren't very
convincing.
Don't I now need,
in fairness,
to do the same thing for the
physicalist?
Don't I need to turn to the
physicalist and say,
"Give me some reason to believe
that physicalism is true?
Give me some reason to believe
souls don't exist."
After all, I turned to the
dualist and said,
"Give me some reason to believe
in souls."
Those arguments didn't work.
Don't I now need to turn to the
physicalist and say,
"Give me some reason not
to believe in souls?
Prove that souls don't
exist."
Isn't that fair?
So let's pause and ask
ourselves, how do you go about
proving that something doesn't
exist?
Or, to put it in a slightly
better way, when do you need to
prove that something doesn't
exist?
When we have examples of things
whose existence we don't believe
in, how do we decide when we're
justified in disbelieving them?
Take something like dragons.
Let me assume that everybody in
this class, in this room,
does not believe in the
existence of dragons.
How do I prove that there
aren't any dragons?
I mean, there could be dragons.
Couldn't there?
But there aren't any.
We don't believe in dragons.
So don't you need to disprove
the existence of dragons before
you continue on your way of not
believing in them?
I imagine nobody in this room
believes in the existence of
Zeus, the Greek god.
How do you disprove the
existence of Zeus?
Don't we have an obligation to
prove that Zeus doesn't exist?
But how could you do that?
Well, unsurprisingly,
I don't actually think you do
have an obligation to disprove
those things.
That doesn't mean you don't
have any obligations.
You just have to be very
careful about what the
intellectual obligations come
to.
So back to dragons.
What do we need to do for
dragons?
Well, the most important thing
you need to do,
to justify your skepticism
about dragons,
is to refute all of the
arguments that might be offered
on behalf of dragons.
My son's got a book about
dragons with some very nice
photographs.
So, one of the things I need to
do in order to justify my
skepticism about dragons is
explain away the photographs,
or the drawings,
or what have you.
I need to explain why it is
that we have pictures,
even though there really aren't
any dragons.
Well, some of these are just
drawings, and people were
drawing things out of their
imagination.
The things that look like
photographs, nowadays with
computer generated graphics,
you can make things that look
like photographs,
and given Photoshop you can
make things that look like
pictures of just about anything
that doesn't even exist.
How do I prove there aren't any
unicorns?
Well, I look at the various
reported sightings of unicorns
and I try to explain them away,
"Well, you know,
it's the first time people,
Europeans, saw the rhinoceros.
It sort of reminded them of a
horse with a big horn.
And maybe that's where the
reports of rhinoceros came--or
the various reports of the
unicorn came from.
The various unicorn horns that
have been offered in various
collections, upon examination by
biologists turn out to be
narwhal horns,
horns from whales,
and so forth and so on."
You look at each bit of
evidence that gets offered on
behalf of the unicorn and you
debunk it.
You explain why it's not
compelling.
And when you're done,
you're entitled to say,
"You know, as far as I can
tell, there aren't any unicorns.
As far as I can tell,
there aren't any dragons."
It's not as though you've got
some obligation to look in every
single cave anywhere on the
surface of the Earth and say,
"Oh, no dragons in there,
no dragons in there,
no dragons in there."
You are pretty much justified
in being skeptical about the
existence of dragons once you've
undermined the arguments for
dragons.
Now, there might be something
more that you could do.
In at least some cases,
you can go on to argue the very
idea of the kind of thing we're
talking about is impossible.
It's not just--Take dragons
again;
it's not just that there's no
good reason to believe in
dragons.
The very idea of a dragon may
be scientifically incoherent,
at least given the science as
we understand it.
I mean, dragons are supposed to
breath fire.
So that must mean they've got
fire in their belly.
But how does the fire continue
to exist in their belly,
absent--lack of oxygen?
Why isn't the fire in their
belly busy burning and
destroying the membranes of
their stomach or whatever?
All right, you could,
I suppose, try to prove that
dragons were scientifically
impossible.
And if you could,
then you'd have an extra reason
to not believe in them.
But it's not as though you have
to prove that something's
impossible to be justified in
not believing in it.
I don't think unicorns are
impossible.
I just don't think there are
any.
Surely, there could be horses
with a single long horn growing
out of their forehead.
There just aren't any.
So armed with these ideas,
come back to the discussion of
souls.
Do I, as a physicalist who does
not believe in the existence of
souls, immaterial entities above
and beyond the body,
do I need to disprove the
existence of souls?
"Well, there's no soul here,
no souls there."
No.
What I need to do is to take a
look at each argument that gets
offered for the existence of a
soul and rebut it--explain why
those arguments are not
compelling.
I don't need to prove that
souls are impossible.
I just need to undermine the
case for souls.
If there's no good reason to
believe in souls,
that actually constitutes a
reason to believe there
are no souls.
Now, if you want to,
you could go on and try to
prove that souls are impossible
in the same way that maybe
dragons are impossible.
But I'm not sure that I myself
find such impossibility claims
especially persuasive.
I don't believe in the
existence of souls,
but that doesn't mean that I
find the idea of an immaterial
entity like the soul impossible.
Now, some people might say,
"Well, you know,
it violates science as we know
it.
It violates physics to have
there be something immaterial."
But science is constantly
coming around to believe in
entities or properties that it
didn't believe in previously.
Maybe it just hasn't gotten
around to believing in souls
yet.
Or if current science rules out
the possibility of souls,
maybe we should say,
"So much the worse for current
science."
So I'm not somebody who wants
to say we can disprove the
existence of souls.
I don't think we can disprove
them.
I don't think the idea of a
soul is in any way incoherent.
There are philosophers who've
thought that.
I'm not one of them.
But I don't think I need to
disprove the existence of a soul
to be justified in not believing
in it.
Unicorns aren't impossible,
but for all that,
I'm justified in thinking there
aren't any.
Why?
Because all the evidence for
unicorns just doesn't add up to
very convincing case.
Souls are not impossible,
but for all that,
I think I'm justified in
believing there aren't any.
Why?
Because when you look for
the--look at the arguments that
have been offered to try to
convince us of the existence of
souls,
those arguments just aren't
very compelling,
or so it seems to me.
So, from this point on out,
I'll be assuming the
physicalist view is correct,
and will be thinking about the
issues of death as they'd be
understood from the physicalist
point of view.